mar 22 heures bonsoir
monsieur françois rey de rassemblement
et toujours deere company 10 litres de
la sécu et des services sociaux du
secteur du b demain qui est encore
national de santé publique du québec
robert au ratio capital et cède la
parole nécessaire doit-on passer par là
au nom du libre bonjour
on recommence et par la situation vous
avez vu hier le québec a atteint un
record de nouveaux co 14000 et
aujourd'hui on est déjà à plus de 16000
c'est un record au québec mais c'est un
record aussi le nombre de coques ont un
vieillard aux états unis en france au
royaume uni quand on regarde dans mon
dos complet tous les pays réunis hier
dieu jamais eu autant de codes en une
journée donc on est vraiment dans une
situation qui est le pays depuis les
vingt deux mois de la pandémie et en
plus avec l'arrivée des tests rapides
qui sont pas nécessairement déclaré par
tout le monde les chiffres qui sont
annoncés de nouveaux co sont
sous-évaluées dont 6 en or plus encore
que ce qui est annoncé
heureusement quand on regarde le nouveau
va bien au micron la plupart des experts
s'entendent pour dire que moins d'impact
sur les hospitalisations que le variant
par exemple delta qu'on avait avant
celui là mais malgré ça compte tenu de
l'importance du nombre de corps depuis
une semaine au québec le nombre
d'hospitalisations est passé de 473 à
900 prend 9 il ya donc se dit que le
nombre d'hospitalisations a doublé ce
qui est très important évidemment le
contenu de la capacité qu'on a dans nos
hôpitaux hier soir avec christian avec
le docteur who dont on a passé du temps
avec les experts de l'institut
national il y est né ce pécule de la
santé publique pardon et avec l'inesss
l'institut national d'excellence en
santé
puis tous les experts qui étaient là
étaient d'accord pour dire que même s'il
reste encore beaucoup d'incertitudes il
ya un risque réel
qui apparaît de dépasser la capacité
hospitalière dans les prochaines
semaines donc on s'est dit la vérité on
était transparent depuis le début de la
pandémie donc je pense est important de
dire aux québécois dans les experts puis
en a plusieurs des docteurs qui
analyse les données soient l'inesss soit
ligne esbly spq sont tous d'accord pour
dire dans les prochaines semaines il ya
un risque que le nombre
d'hospitalisations
dépasse notre capacité donc ce qui nous
amènerait éventuellement ne plus être
capable de soigner tout le monde au
québec donc c'est quand même très graves
comme situation et si une chose que j'ai
apprise
depuis le début de la pandémie c'est
qu'on doit j'ai rapidement la situation
évolue rapidement
puis comme décideur on a la
responsabilité
d'âgés évidemment on pourrait attendre
toutes sortes d'études des plus de
précisions mais c'est mieux d'âge et qui
est à ajuster
un peu plus tard donc ce soir
malheureusement on veut se donner des
mesures on va se donner un grand coup à
partir de demain d'abord on va
malheureusement fermé les salles des
restaurants donc les restaurants on
pourra continuer a pas de la durée sont
les gens mon poids n'est chercher de la
nourriture mais malheureusement pour pas
garder les salles ouvertes maintenant
les rassemblements river
les rassemblements dans les maisons
seront plus permis à partir de demain
donc c'est important de le comprendre il
va y avoir les mêmes exceptions qu'on a
déjà eu à d'autres moments c'est à dire
les personnes qui ont besoin d'un projet
d'un d'une prochaine dans tsw 1/2 c les
personnes qui sont seules vont pouvoir
continuer de s'ajouter à une autre bulle
n'est pour les personnes qui vivent en
couple ou en groupe ça sera plus
possible d'aller faire des
rassemblements avec des gens d'autres
bulles le gros sujet évidemment puis la
question qu'on s'est posée depuis
quelques jours
c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait avec le
couvre-feu puis je veux prendre le temps
de l'expliquer d'expliquer les enjeux
comme il faut aux québécois d'abord il
ya des gens qui peuvent dire étant
l'anict et restaurants sont fermés les
salles de spectacles sont fermés on n'a
pas le droit d'aller visiter ses amis
pour quoi on mettrait un couvre feu bon
effectivement la majorité des québécois
respectent les consignes ça devrait être
suffisant par conte on sait qu'une
minorité qui respectent pas les
consignes ça a un impact
évidemment ce leur situation se retrouve
plus nombreux à l'hôpital et donc c'est
important de poids s'assurer que tout le
monde respecte les conseillers demandent
quand on parle aussi aux policiers
si on disait par exemple on met un
couvre-feu seulement pour les non
vaccinés ça serait à peu près impossible
pour les policiers de de faire appliquer
ce règlement là c'est applicable si on
dit ben à partir d'une certaine heure il
ya plus personne qui peut être dans les
rues comme ça c'est plus facile
policiers et donc c'est applicable et on
pense que c'est nécessaire d'aller leur
pour s'assurer
justement que on a les contacts l'opo
arrêté
l'accélération du nombre
d'hospitalisations donc malheureusement
je vous annonce qu'à partir de demain
soir de 22h à 5h du matin il y aura un
coup refusé dès que les personnes qui
n'ont pas d'affaires est à l'extérieur
samedi compo un papier de leur employeur
ou autres bains vont être passible d'une
amende d'au moins 1000 de danse de
palais jusqu'à 6000 $ donc on va être
est la clé policiers puis évidemment
c'est un geste qui est extrême parce que
la situation est extrême pilotes ce soir
je prendre un engagement devant tous les
québécois
le premier assouplissement qu'on va
faire quand la situation va redevenir
contrôle dans les hôpitaux ça va être de
l'enlever ce couvre-feu donc ce n'est
pas par plaisir qu'on fait c'est par
nécessité pour sauver notre réseau plus
beau sauver des vies
concernant les autres activités
malheureusement des sports intérieurs
pourront plus être permis évidemment les
règles qu'on avait déjà mise concernant
le télétravail vont rester on s'est
aussi posé beaucoup de questions sur les
écoles vous savez pour notre
gouvernement
c'est ce qui est plus important nos
enfants nos jeunes soient à l'école et
c'était prévu il demain que les écoles
rouvrent le 10 janvier bon on sait puis
j'ai entendu beaucoup de parents d'ella
leur inquiétude
pour un retour éventuel le 10 janvier
j'ai entendu aussi des enseignants
depuis hier les enseignants ont le droit
d'aller chercher leur troisième dose
mais il ya des enseignants qui se
demande ce que je vais être capable
de le faire du style 10 janvier est
évidemment aussi
les écoles mais c'est un endroit où il
ya des éclosions où il ya beaucoup de
gens où il y aura un risque plus grand
donc j'annonce que toutes les écoles les
cégeps les universités vont rester
fermés jusqu'au 17 janvier donc le lundi
17 janvier
on va tout faire pour rouvrir les écoles
et évidemment il ya des gens qui vont
c'est ouais mais dans le passé on n'a
pas été capable toujours de respecter
les dates qu'on s'était donné moi je
vais vous dire un envoi 3 pour ouvrir
les écoles de 17 janvier puis deux mais
c'est ce sont les premiers
établissements on vous retrouverez donc
c'est vraiment là la priorité avant
avant tout pour ce qui est des services
de garde des services de garde réguliers
vont continuer d'être sûrs que les
services de garde qui a dans les écoles
vont indisponible mais seulement pour
les travailleurs qui donne des services
qui sont essentiels
revenir sur la situation dans les
hôpitaux
évidemment je le disais tantôt depuis
une semaine en seulement une semaine le
nombre de coco vide dans les hôpitaux
d'oubli née en même temps le nombre
d'employés absent a plus que doublé on
est passé en fait depuis une semaine de
5600 employés absents à 12 même 500
employés absents donc j'ai pas besoin de
vous dire que ces deux effets combinés
donc une augmentation du nombre
d'hospitalisations une diminution du
nombre d'infirmières de médecins de
personnel dans les hôpitaux ça fait
qu'il ya un risque encore plus grand de
rupture donc pu être capable de donner
des services à tout le monde pour ce que
le ministre de la santé a annoncé cette
semaine qu'on regarde la possibilité que
des employés ce soit des infirmières ou
des médecins qui ont eu la coved
mettions
moins de symptômes ou plus de saint pons
de pouvoir revenir plus rapidement mais
on va le faire seulement aux endroits où
c'est absolument nécessaire donc on
comprend tout cela c'est pas idéal
l'enam temps sont un choix en entre se
faire soigner par un employé avec un
masque n 95 ou ne pas se faire soigner
du tout tout le monde doit être d'accord
pour dire c'est mieux au moins d'avoir
quelqu'un avec un masque n95 que je veux
en passant rassurer tout le monde on a
assez de masques 95 pour les prochaines
semaines donc ça c'est pas un enjeu
bon évidemment je veux m'adresser à tous
ceux et celles qui travaillent dans nos
hôpitaux nos ch celle des
je suis très conscient que ça fait 22
mois que c'est dur
mais
malheureusement on a besoin de vous au
plus que jamais
actuellement on est dans une tempête
puis la tempête est à son maximum
actuellement donc on a besoin de vous au
repos croire que d'un prochaines
semaines on va laisser des québécois
sans soins donc on a vraiment besoin de
vous autres et s'il vous plaît si vous
êtes capable de venir aider vos
collègues s'il vous plaît on a besoin
vraiment de vous on
se parlait des employés du réseau de la
santé mais on commence à voir un
problème ou si dans d'autres secteurs ça
soit les éducatrices en garderie que ça
soit des camionneurs ce soit des
chauffeurs d'autobus cela soit des gens
dans construction on voit de plus en
plus qu'à des secteurs
qui à cause du nombre des personnes qui
ont la colline peuvent plus fonctionner
normalement donc c'est toute la société
qui
actuellement est fragilisé et c'est vrai
aussi dans les commerces même les
commerces essentiel commence à y avoir
de plus en plus de juin qui
malheureusement
on l'a connue depuis peuvent donc pas
venir travailler ne viennent pas
travailler et c'est important
de reprendre une mesure qu'on avait
mises en place l'année dernière c'était
de fermer les commerces le dimanche pour
donner une chance aux commerces qui
manque d'employés au moins d'avoir une
journée de répit donc pour les trois
prochains dimanches les commerces vont
être fermés au québec
entre-temps revue le nombre de troisième
dose qui sont donnés à chaque jour
arrête pas d'augmenter on a vraiment une
armée de personnes de vaccinateurs qui
travaillent est ce important quand c'est
rendu voto d'aller chercher votre
troisième dose je répète deux chiffres
que certains experts nous disent avec
deux doses vous êtes protégé à 30 % avec
3 donne vous êtes protège à
75% donc c'est toute une différence
c'est très important d'aller chercher la
3e d'autres
prochain sujet que je vous prie les
personnes qui refusent de se faire
vacciner
je répète là aussi les chiffres
actuellement quand on regarde les
adultes non vaccinés c'est à peu près
10% de la population mais c'est 50 % des
hospitalisations
donc si vous faites une règle de 3 10% à
50% ça c'est les non-vaccinés lokoti 90%
qui représentent 50% samedi que les non
vaccinés ont dix fois plus de chance
d'être hospitalisé mais moi je voudrais
vous mettiez à la place des infirmières
des médecins du personnel qui voit
arriver la moitié des patients qui sont
là beaucoup parce qu'ils ont pour l'été
ou ont fusé les vacciner donc je
comprends qu'une certaine colère puis
c'est vrai aussi chez beaucoup de
québécois on a actuellement des
québécois même jouait sur les médias
sociaux qui suggère qu'on arrête de
soigner les personnes qui veulent pas se
faire vacciner c'est pas le genre de
société qu'on veut au québec plat donc
on y re pas dans cette direction là est
par contre ce que j'ai demandé à mon
équipe c'est de voir comment on peut
élargir l'utilisation du passeport voxna
ça veut dire que dans plus de sortes de
commerces dans plus de lieux qu'on exige
de plus en plus le passeport vaccinale
pour protéger les non vaccinés contre
eux mêmes parce que s'il y attrape le
virus ont dix fois plus de chances de se
ramasser à l'hôpital avec des
conséquences graves qui peuvent aller
jusqu'au décès il pense c'est important
aussi qu'on fasse un effort
pour donner sapin davantage aux vacciner
une question d'équité
je termine en vous disant que évidemment
c'est pô le genre de fin d'année que je
reste souhaité mais on a tous eu droit
on a tous un devoir de tout faire pour
que tout le monde soit soigné au québec
pour qu'on sauver le maximum de vies et
les 10 ou 20 le peuple québécois or une
cohésion sociale extraordinaire donc
faussée des
îles des gens dans les prochains jours
qui vont intéresser vont être anxieux
vont être tristes
n'hésitez pas à appeler quelqu'un c'est
important d'en parler à quelqu'un qui se
sent bien destin portant d'appeler les
personnes qui sont seules on va vivre
des jours très durs
et c'est important plus que jamais de
prendre soin les uns des autres entre
temps évidemment dans deux jours on va
voir une nouvelle année donc on va tous
se souhaiter que 2022 qui est moins de
virus qui on est plus de nouvelles
joyeuse à partager donc à tout le monde
à tous les québécois
bonanni 2022 karmann merci
que des voeux ning every one hour
experts
un nouveau
grand coup
de mer
[Musique]
annoncé nick young
il pourra pas recevoir déjà sous
pression
malraux
tout
cas n'a pas si on sera chose que je dois
les choses très haut débit
sans
[Musique]
démesure je suis content du zinc et que
je saute et le
[Musique]
brésil ce
qui complète les allocutions on va
maintenant débuter la période de
questions des journalistes nous avons
des journalistes ici dans la salle de
micros sont disposés de part et d'autre
de la salle on a aussi des journalistes
qui sont présents avec nous sur zone en
virtuel nous allons débuter au micro un
avec radio canada
oui je parlais aujourd'hui au docteur le
bois l'eau de l'inesss et il annick pas
de variables dans ses calculs pour
dénombrer le nombre de personnes qui ont
la cote 19 actuellement au québec parce
que beaucoup de gens qui passent des
tests rapides à la maison qui sont pas
dans les données saez mail aujourd'hui
on disait ma question elle est simple et
compliqué à la fois avez vous perdu le
contrôle sur la gestion de la pandémie
si oui est-ce que qu'est ce qui explique
que vous avez perdu le contrôle et sinon
qu'est ce qui nous rassure qu'est ce qui
vous fait dire que vous n'avez pas perdu
le contrôle de ce qui se passe
actuellement dans la province je suis
peut-être pour commencer j'ai pris mes
deux collègues poursuit d'abord docta le
guano était la rencontre hier soir et
effectivement
j'ai dit en tout le nombre de corps est
actuellement sous estimé au québec et
ailleurs dans le monde à cause des tests
rapides ce qu'on suit de très proche
c'est le nombre d'hospitalisations
surtout le nombre d'hospitalisations aux
soins intensifs c'est là dessus qu'on se
comprend qu'on regarde l'évolution c'est
vraiment ce qui nous permet de bien voir
bien lire la situation
parce que vous lui non je pense que
c'est bien dit je pense que là on a au
nom on a le contrôle sur les
hospitalisations puisque ce que nous ont
montré le docteur baudot hier je suis
exactement les courbes que qu'on
s'attarde est malheureusement on aurait
espéré xing roubles soit meilleur mais
c'est exactement ce qu'on s'attendait
parfait j'ai une belle relance ou une
autre question
vous avez parlé des non vaccinés en
disant que certains commerces là qui
vont exiger dorénavant le passeport
vaccinale on voit que d'autres pays vont
beaucoup plus loin en exigeant transport
vaccinale par tout en demandant à la
population doit être vacciné points
comme en allemagne on a l'impression que
les vaccinés paye encore le prix pour
les non vaccinés qu'est ce que vous
allez faire de plus pour non pas les
vues pullulent dans les conférences de
presse mais qu'est ce que vous allez
faire de plus pour convaincre ces gens
là de se faire vacciner au québec
d'abord comme je l'expliquais tantôt si
on avait été capable de mettre un
couvre-feu spécial juste les
non-vaccinés puis de le faire respecter
c'est qu'une quelque chose qu'on avait
regardé maintenant
faut voir si en élargissant
l'utilisation du passeport vaccinale 6
applicables je vous donne un exemple
parce qu'un très petit commerce ce prêt
est équipé pour vérifier la vaccination
de tous les clients
probablement dans les plus grands
commerces on pourrait étendre
effectivement ça se voie pas seulement
les restaurants pas seulement les
youtube donc je demandais à mon équipe
de d partout on va être capable en
pratique de mettre deux passeports
vaccinale on veut le même
genre ajoute un élément par contre que
très important les vaccinés vous vous
êtes fait le plus beau cadeau je vais
vous dire ça parce que si actuellement
vous n'étiez pas vacciner deux doses
mais vous seriez peut-être beaucoup de
gens ça l'hôpital actuellement peut-être
moi même je serai peut-être rendu à
l'hôpital avec eux aux soins intensifs
je comprends la frustration des gens
ongles mais si jamais on avait eu des
taux de couverture vaccinale beaucoup
plus beau conte au québec je peux vous
dire que notre système de soins seraient
dans le province n'a fait que sur une
chose pour que les québécois roczen
c'est que la vaccination ça demeure très
important et c'est probablement la
meilleure chose que vous avez fait pour
vous aider vous et aider d'autres
personnes ne pas se retrouver lecteurs
mais pas d'autres mesures à venir pour
les non vaccinés
je comprends mais ce que je voudrais pas
que j'en pense c'est que moi je me suis
fait vacciner salle est servi à rien je
vous comprenez je comprends qu'on ait
pris absolument dans un contexte si on
doit prendre des mesures fortes de
mesure populationnelle qu'on n'a pas le
goût de prendre pour justement protéger
encore notre système de soins pour qu'on
peut se traiter les artistes ratés tout
le monde actuellement donc je me sens
très complet qu'on comprenne que la
vaccination ça leur a servi parce que
sinon serait pas là aujourd'hui
une question un
nouveau coup effectivement monsieur
legault dit mon onze de man band où un
couvre-feu au début de l'année de
janvier à mai maintenant romain autre
couvre feu est ce qu'on a vraiment
observé une corrélation entre le couvre
feu et la baisse des cas
d'abord c'est très difficile d'isoler
une mesure dans un contexte comme on
connaît actuellement parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de mesures une situation qui
change qui est différente d'un pays à
l'autre donc c'est très difficile
d'évaluer une mesure par cons on a des
indications que c'est utile puis
actuellement la situation est tellement
agréable qu'on peut pas se permettre de
propos ne pas ajouter dans notre coffre
à outils tout ce qu'on est capable
d'ajouter il ya une question aussi de
gros bon sens si on dit les gens doivent
être chez eux à 10 heures le soir ben ce
qu'ils voulaient faire le porter jusqu'à
une heure du matin ben c'est plus
difficile parce qu'il ya des policiers
qui peuvent vérifier donc une question
de gros bon sens de 10 c'est clair que
ça ça aide à réduire le nombre de
contacts j'ai reçu beaucoup de questions
de parents et ceux non le 17 janvier ce
qu'il y aura de l'école virtuelle avant
où c'est vraiment la rentrée à partir du
17 oui tout partout ça sera possible
d'avoir de l'école virtuelle virtuel il
y en aura
ce qui est important aussi pour rassurer
certains parents qui ont des enfants qui
ont besoin de services spécialisés que
ces services là vont continuer de donner
aussi
d'ici le 17 janvier donc comme seconde à
cégep universités je pense qu'il aurait
pas de problème à ce que de la formation
qui se donne à distance donc pas tout ça
sera possible d'en faire qu'on va enfin
peut-être monsieur croyais ministre sur
les écoles il y aura des annonces
spécifiques dans les prochains jours
pour le retour en classe autant au
niveau du primaire secondaire que des
écoles supérieures
merci toujours au micro de jean françois
tremblay de tva nouvelles
bonjour monsieur legault on sent qu'il
ya beaucoup de grogne présentement dans
la population qui sans gouvernement un
peu désorganisé parfois qu'on pense aux
files d'attentes tout le monde les a vus
vous l'avez sûrement vu aux cliniques de
dépistage des gens malades qui attendent
des heures
[Musique]
trouver des trousses pour avoir les
tests rapides ça devient complexe est
vraiment pas tous les citoyens qui
réussissent à en avoir est-ce que la
vitesse de propagation vous un peu
dépassée quelque part au gouvernement
écoutez comme vous dirais comme comme
partout dans le monde lorsqu'on regarde
les statistiques
de penser enfin en comparaison même si
c'est moins pire ici que ce qu'on voit
présentement en europe c'est quand même
des volumes de 10 fois qu'on avait dans
les vagues précédent donc c'est alors ce
qui ce qui est l'enjeu pour nous c'est
de s'ajuster à chaque fois au niveau du
dépistage
on a une capacité technique maximale de
50 mille tonnes par jour alors c'est
pour ce qu'on a pensé aux tests rapides
pour être capable d'avoir au moins des
gens qui puissent se faire leur auto
tester malheureusement puis je pas en
faire un des bonnes mais on est
dépendant de ce qu'on reçoit du fédéral
au niveau des autotests alors on a pris
des mesures dans les dernières semaines
on va les chercher nous mêmes des tests
sur le marché mondial pour être capable
d'avoir alors le monde aux gens de
comprendre qu'en ce moment on est pris
dans une situation mondiale qui pour
certains ont des ressemblances avec la
première balle parce que tout le monde
est pris avec la démesure des mesures
exceptionnelles par quand je dirais aux
gens de s'encourager parce qu'on se
réorganise on en a ajusté la façon dont
les gens doivent aller se faire tester
lorsqu'on dit je redis lorsque les
genres des symptômes qu'ils restent à la
maison parce que ça donne rien d'aller
se faire auto tester tout de suite et en
ce moment comme on est limité dans le
nombre de tests qu'on peut faire ben je
passe les gens le comprennent qu'on est
mieux de rester à la maison si on
additionnait des symptômes puis je vous
en a pris l'engagement que le plus
rapidement possible qu'on aurait d'hôtes
au total on va les distribuer dans les
pharmacies
et plusieurs citoyens qui ont été testés
positifs après avoir reçu leur deuxième
dojo des sursauts québec aujourd'hui qui
affirme que ces citoyens là n'auraient
pas besoin de leur troisième d'eau vous
de leur dose de rappel est-ce que celle
qu un citoyen qui a reçu deux doses qui
a attrapé la cabine maintenant et ce
kilo oui ou non besoin d'une troisième
dose les recommandations d'experts
actuellement démontre que si vous faites
vie reçue deux doses d'un arn messagers
father of modern art et que vous faites
la maladie cette maladie là vous
confirme comme s'il était une 3e dos et
là la recommandation actuelle
ce qui est important ce sont des
symptômes blavec bâtisse pour steve vaut
probablement être plus valide un gros
considère que c'est une troisième dose
et pour le passeport vaccinale ça va se
passer comme un pur citoyens qui sont
dans cette situation là on est en train
de parce que l'enjeu puis bien
journaliste qui me l'a posée cette
semaine là je sais qu est ce qu on fait
avec les gens qui s'auto qui se
détestent pour être capable de le faire
alors on en a pris une décision dans les
derniers jours qui a ouvert un site web
convoi rend disponible où les gens vont
pouvoir s'inscrire le fait qu'ils ont
fait un dépistage on va voir si on peut
faire un mariage mais neuf luxe et de
l'information qui sur une base
volontaire on n'est pas en train de
regarder comment on peut faire deux le
pairage avec l'autre information qu'on a
dans nos systèmes mais c'est sûr que
tous ceux des boules très très vite puis
on en demandait non j'en informatique de
nous faire une proposition devrait être
en place dans les prochaines semaines
merci prochaines questions à marie
provost le devoir oui bonjour est ce que
le retour du couvre feu pourrait perdre
vu comme un signe de l'échec de la
gestion de la pandémie nos alliés
dernières semaines derniers mois au
québec
quand on regarde la situation
je suis content garder chez je disais la
hilaire on a eu un repas à peu près
partout si on regarde par exemple les
hospitalisations par million d'habitants
actuellement il ya deux fois plus
d'hospitalisations dans l'ensemble des
états unis qu'au québec donc
est ce que ça veut dire qu'on s'en va là
actuellement on a la moitié moins de
corps cause d'hospitalisation qu aux
etats-unis dont la situation qu'on garde
en ontario on est à peu près au même
niveau quand on garde les soins
intensifs en tassant 30 les autres sont
à 2 1 donc c'est à peu près là quand on
tient compte de la population le même
niveau le nombre de codes ça dépend
combien on fait test donc faut être
prudent quand on compare mais on n'y a
pas lieu de croire actuellement que on
est dans une situation pecik ailleurs
puis peut-être ce que j'aimerais ajouter
rappelez vous de ce qu'on a appris dans
la première vague par exemple au niveau
nos ch et celle de haut niveau on le
sait le comment ça a été excessivement
difficile on n'est pas du tout dans la
même situation parce que justement on à
maximiser la vaccination de nogent dans
les chu 7d oui déjà qu'ils sont infectés
qu'en ce moment dans les chu celle des
mêmes part au micro mais c'est des gens
qui sont beaucoup moins malade sait déjà
qu'ils manquent de rien ce moment même
c'est très difficile alors voudrais
juste qu'on fasse attention que de dire
oui la situation est très difficile
c'est un virus qui est incroyable mais
en ce moment on est quand même capable
de soigner nos gens et c'est pour ça
qu'on a ainsi sur le principal remède
qui est la vaccination il faut se le
rappeler alors quand on on insiste puis
on répète je sais qu'on le répète
beaucoup mais nos gens de nogent de 60
ans et plus sont en train de se faire
vacciner à ce moment ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle est le premier ministre a
répété allez vous faire vacciner dans
les prochains jours et on commence la
vaccination générale de la population
la semaine prochaine donc on est
vraiment sûr sur la boule on est
vraiment en train de de focus et pour
être sûr qu on donne le maximum de
protection à nogent malgré un virus qui
est incroyable
sinon je me demandais il ya dessous
cette question d'accepter de
l'acceptabilité avec une nouvelle mesure
qui prêtent moins grande cet hiver parce
que bon les gens ont eu la majeure
partie des gens ou l'ordre dawes ya
moins de décès il ya la perception qu
micron est peut-être moins dangereux que
beaucoup de gens qui ont déjà été
positifs qui ont des jeux le virus donc
est-ce que vous pensez que ça va pas
nuire un peu à l'adhésion de la
population
ouais mais en fait regardez on a connaît
tous déjà dans les derniers jours qui se
sont fait contaminée ce qui est décevant
je vois commencer par le côté négatif ce
qui est décevant les gens se disent j'ai
eu deux doses que je lis à attraper
quand même mais on est beaucoup moins
malade regardez il a déjà quand ils ont
eu deux grosses pluies qui a trait aux
migrants ils se disent l'enfant là j'en
ai pour deux trois jours c'était
difficile pis ça parle ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle c'est parce que vous vous êtes
fait vacciner si vous étiez pas vacciner
vous auriez été probants l'hôpital puis
encore plus aux soins intensifs faut pas
que les gens oublient sommes maintenant
jade le répète ce que le premier
ministre se dit est-ce que vous aimez
mieux être protégée à 30 pour ça pour un
micro vous aimez mieux être protégée à
75 ou 80 pour ça parce que de passer à
travers la maladie pendant deux trois
jours ce correct mais c'est quoi les
conséquences à long terme que vous
pouvez attraper de la maladie c'est ça
qu'il faut faire attention vis deuxième
quand vous avez la troisième dose vous
êtes beaucoup moins contagieux pour les
autres alors oui pensez à vous vous
allez être mieux protégés mais penser
qu'avec la troisième dose vous allez
être moins contagieux si jamais voulu
l'attraper et soit pour vos proches
particulièrement dans le temps des fêtes
et dans l'hiver où on peut on est plus à
l'intérieur je pense que toutes les
raisons du monde toutes les raisons du
monde d'aller se faire vacciner de la
troisième donc peu importe large bande
au micro de florence martel la presse il
bonjour est compte tenu de la situation
actuelle et comptez vous repoussez la
deuxième dose de 5 à 11 ans et pour
accélérer la troisième dose des détails
plus et du personnel la santé
je suis très honnêtement actuellement ce
sont des priorités et on va s'organiser
pour le faire la capacité de ta part et
d'autre monsieur paris
ce pari est en train de planifier les
deux et on devrait véritablement arrivé
à faire la démarche
aussi j'utilise hospitalisation elle
cela couvait 19 épisodes sont des gens
qui viennent à l'urgence pour autre
chose qu'ils apprennent qu'ils ont la
kfw 19 une fois à l'hôpital est ce qu'on
est capable de quantifier le nombre des
cas comme ceux dans les gîtes retient
estimer la durée moyenne du séjour de
ces gens-là ça c'est si on est en train
de le regarder parce qu'on sait c'est
notre grande préoccupation parce que des
deux question c'est est-ce que les
229 hospitalisation qu'on a eues
aujourd'hui ses 229 personnes qui sont
rentrées à l'hôpital la cause la coque
vide je vous ai dit un peu plus tôt
cette semaine qu'on pense quant à peu
près de 25 pour ça qu'ils sont rentrés à
l'hôpital pour d'autres raisons je vous
ai donné l'exemple d'une personne une
femme qui vient d'accoucher et lorsqu'on
lattès l éco villes elle est pas venu
pour la coved mais devenu pour
raccrocher on est en train d'essayer
d'extraire ces cols donc ça c'est une
chose qu'on fait c'est très difficile en
ce moment pour nous demander à lunesse
pq de nous revenir je sais pas si le
docteur arruda eu parce qu'on a
tellement question c'est ces temps ci
m'ont demandé de dire maintenant qu'on
est plus beaucoup plus aux migrants plq
on est presque plus de delta dans les
côtes iran quelle est la durée moyenne
d'hospitalisation et saas et j'espère
qu'on est capable d'avoir soit dans les
prochains jours mais je vous rappellerai
une statistique depuis déjà qui parce
qu'on suit beaucoup sont pas juste nous
mais les gens commencent à comprendre
que c'est plus uniquement les com et des
hospitalisations
c'est d'encourager les gens pour être
capable de suivre correctement ce qu'il
faut regarder c'est le nombre d'entre
eux le nombre d'entrants au niveau des
hospitalisations hier il est à 229
demain il va et à 260 ça veut dire que
il rentre 260 personnes infectées pour
des raisons que j'ai du talent mais
peut-être 25% tôt mais ils ont quand
même ce qui est important c'est de voir
les sorties moi je m'encourage et si tu
peux voir des sorties qui viennent
montée demain ils vont voir 164 sortie
ce qui est encourageant c'est que 164
sortie si nous entraider ya sept huit
jours etc c'est sûr qu'on va être
capable de voir quand on aura un
échantillon assez précis est ce qu'on
est en train de prendre le dessus
lorsque les entrées vont régaler les
sorties on n'est pas dans cette courbe
là ce moment mais les des statistiques
ons de vue de l'inesss de mines spq du
docteur boileau de tout le monde qui
nous aident là-dedans montrent cette
courbe elle est très pointu donc oui ça
monte très vite mais j'espère qu'on
pourra voir un fléchissement de la
courbe dans l'est dans les prochaines
semaines rapidement mais c'est ce qu'on
suit de très proches en ce moment puis
je veux rassurer les gens on va
continuer malgré les failles des très
transparent dans nos données donc les
gens plus boire justement ce qu'on est
un an après avec les des mesures très
difficiles qu'on annonce aujourd'hui de
reprendre le dessus parce que cette
barrière le maire parce qu'on le connaît
mais
virulence incroyable
on va poursuivre avec les journalistes
francophones qui sont sur la plateforme
avec nous la même règle s'appliquait
questions suggestions en débutant avec
sarah moscou pour le réseau cogeco
mais bonjour à nous trois ma question
est pour monsieur leubou le travail du
docteur aruba est de plus en plus remis
en question par des analystes qui lui
reprochent notamment d'être car sur la
science est il toujours la bonne
personne pour diriger la santé publique
du québec oui
parce que c'est votre seule réponse non
mais écoutez évidemment il ya beaucoup
d'incertitudes l'appui on a pris les
bonnes décisions plus 22 mois et il rien
de noir ou blanc donc
moi je pense qu'on a des bons avis qui
sont donné des bonnes discussions que
doctor who do avec les deux instituts
qu'on rencontre une fois par semaine
donc je pense qu'on a toutes les
expertises nécessaires pour prendre les
meilleures décisions mais comme je
disais au début je pense que l'important
c'est de prendre des décisions
rapidement et depuis 22 mois ben c'est
arrivé souvent que
d'autres juridictions
d'autres états nous ont suivis mais avec
une semaine deux semaines plus tard donc
je pense qu on est en avant de la parade
puis c'est important de rester comme ça
hop c'est un programme haut d'octobre
parfait massou question vous parlez de
décision rapide à l'instant pourquoi
avoir attendu aujourd'hui pour
l'annoncer restriction est ce que vous
voyez sauter la fête de noël donc pas du
tout parce que là évidemment qu'avec les
décisions qu'on annonce aujourd'hui on
vient de gâcher beaucoup les festivités
du jour de l'an je pense que ce qui est
important c'est de se fier à science et
puis cette semaine les experts nous ont
dit mais là on a un peu plus de
certitude sur le fait que si on fait
rien il ya un risque de débordement des
hôpitaux donc dès qu'on a cette
information là le hier soir on agit dès
aujourd'hui
merci merci prochain journaliste est
l'art à la presse canadienne
bonjour clara le soleil de l'après steve
ce que j'aimerais savoir c'est que bon
l'inesss aussi que selon ses prédictions
ça se peut qu'on dépasse le niveau 3 de
délestage des
champions donc je voulais savoir à quel
point on est sûr qu'on va réussir à ne
pas
alors que les actions montent
mais je pense que deux variables sont
très très bonne question parce que j'ai
essayé de vous le mettre à un chiffre
pour encore une fois faire le lien avec
ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure vous avez
vu que dans le sommaire qui est présenté
tous les jours par santé québec la
caisse la capacité des hospitalisations
et des pensées d'hier à aujourd'hui 2
812 mon avis sur le joueur ici dans la
salle des gens disent oui on suit ça
tout le monde pourquoi ça a monté ce
parce qu'on augmente et le délestage
c'est malheureux mais c'est pour ne plus
de délestage en ce moment de chirurgies
non urgentes
si vite et moins urgent parce qu'on se
prépare parce que lorsqu'ils rentrent
225 nouvelles hospitalisations par jour
puis quand sort 130-140 c'est sûr qu'on
va se rendre à 1200 alors si pour ça que
on a un enjeu d'augmentation et c'est
pour ça que c'est exactement ce que le
premier ministre dit hier quand on a vu
qu'on se rapprochait de la halle à
raison de 2 125 et demain je vous dis ça
va être deux cent soixante donc on se
rapproche de ce fossé la première jours
le deuxième problème c'est qu'on a eu
moins d'un moins de personnel avec le
délestage c'est une chose mais si on a
moins de personnes pour soigner ben
c'est sûr qu'on a deux problèmes comme
le premier ministre donc est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on a plus de chance de se
rendre délestage de niveau 3 ou même de
niveau 4 dans certaines régions donnent
les régions à titre d'exemple pour pour
inquiéter les gens mais par exemple en
estrie ou à laval en ce moment c'est
beaucoup plus critique c'est pas pareil
partout mais il ya des endroits où c'est
plus critique alors c'est pour ça qu'on
a fait une autre mesure cette semaine
qui est très difficile c'est ce qu'on
appelait le réalignement des personnes
pour demander quand vous êtes un
symptomatique de venir nous aider et je
répète déjà nous travailleurs de la
santé ont fait un travail incroyable
depuis mai mais là on a besoin que
d'autres personnes viennent nous aider
ça on va continuer à discuter avec les
syndicats on leur parle encore demain je
le sais que c'est pas facile mais je
vous dis il ya une combinaison de les
québécois ce qui peut le faire avec le
couvre-feu dans les prochains jours ça
c'est une chose mais nos travailleurs de
la santé à qui on ne demande à quand je
demande à tout le monde de travailler en
équipe tout le monde doit travailler en
équipe pour qu'on soit capable de post
rendent à cette villa puis d'aller dans
des délestages de niveau 3 et 4 la
personne du
j'ajouterai peut-être une chose si c'est
malheureusement
crise et en ait deux comptables sont
habitude avec des chiffres mais quand
ont-elles d'inès ou alien spq bonson
ferme les restaurants si on empêche les
rassemble mains privées somme un
couvre-feu ckoi l'impact sur les courbes
prévu des prochaines semaines la réponse
de la peau noir sur blanc c'est grand
intervalle l'appui il n'y a pas de
réponse précise la part des experts
parce que ces dix il n'y a pas assez
d'expérience sur chaque mesure pour être
capable de voir quel sera l'impact de
nos mesures mais nous on est confiant
quand même avec une de façon raisonnable
que les mesures qu'on annonce
aujourd'hui vont nous permettre de
passer au travers mais c'est pas une
science précise
malheureusement
ces questions je me demandais où si
aujourd'hui on annonce des mesures sont
quand même assez intense justement la
comparaison il ya un mois
donc ces personnes qui se demandent est
ce mieux de
laisser moins de liberté un moyen
pour aujourd'hui peut-être pas avoir
deux
mois je vous mets au défi de
trouver quelqu'un moi qui prévoyait qu
on aurait six mille nouveaux corps par
jour au québec aujourd'hui
des années la situation évolue et on
s'ajuste au fur et à mesure de
l'évolution qu'on s'ajuste rapidement
si vous me permettez l'adhésion de la
population est aussi associée à sa
perception du risque je pense vous
comprenez on parle beaucoup le cas il
faut maintenir l'adhésion des gens avec
cette erreur il faut les laisser vivre
et il est donc on est les gens rapport
du tout aimé qu'on maintienne des
mesures alors que l'écho était pas élevé
qu'on était en contrôle des situations
faut toujours prendre en considération
comment le patient la population va
recevoir notre recommandation moi je dis
une chose que je veux je veux dire
aujourd'hui qui est importante il ya
même encore quelques semaines il experts
locaux
nationaux mondiaux n'étaient même pas
capable de dire si les verts les vaccins
actuels qu'on avait protégé ou non
contre le virus on se demandait il ya
quelques semaines de dire écoutez c'est
ce que ça protège à 80% à cent-pour-cent
à 30% on ne savait pas et c'est là que
je vous dis quand on regardera donc on
dira qu est ce qu ont eu comme
information à partir du 15 décembre
du 17 décembre du 19 des arts à tous les
jours quand ces choses là se sont
précisées autant au niveau canadien
qu'au niveau mondial ben c'est là qu'on
a pu agir parce qu'on a dit écoutez si
la terre d'errance mai et on a fait des
mesures par étapes alors je pense pour
aujourd'hui avec l'information qu'on a
eu une année derniers jours on a décidé
de fouiller dans le coffre à outils pour
le premier ministre dit puis si c'est
avec soin est ce que c'est de gaieté de
coeur qu'on le fait aujourd'hui et pour
personne si on avait marqué deux buts
mais est ce que c'est la bonne chose à
faire dans les circonstances on est
complet du bruit nous avons poursuivi
avec patrick pellerot journal de québec
journal de montréal
oui bonjour à tous les trois sur le goût
vous avez expliqué dans toutes les
situations et pérouse unis similaire en
ontario monsieur dubé rappelé en début
de semaine qui a toujours beaucoup de
besoins syntaxe sont imposés on a créé
le taux de couverture vaccinale
qu'est-ce qui fait le colloque qu'on
soit là sous juridiction sont pas rares
au burkina à devoir et posant pour un
flou pour une deuxième année
il ya plusieurs explications d'abord
vous savez monsieur belle roscoe aux
états unis entre haute et que réseau
privé des hôpitaux il ya beaucoup plus
de lits est beaucoup plus de capacités
qu'on a au canada ou au québec
ensuite écouté quand on regarde le
personnel ben c'est un problème qui date
pas d'hier au québec le fait qu'on
pour tout le personnel qu'on aimerait
avoir il ya des postes qui sont affichés
d'infirmières qui sont pas comblés il ya
40 % des infirmières qui sont à temps
partiel donc ça mais des enjeux donc
évidemment c'est difficile de comparer
des situations
d'un état avec un autre état mais il
reste que nous on pense que c'est mieux
d'âge est plutôt que plus tard
ascain et sur la question de l'adhésion
la question se pose dans tout jeu vous
entendre monsieur legault après
vingt-deux revoir les québécois ont
l'impression qu'ils ont pas mal tout
faire pour combattre le virus est ce que
vous craignez que la population des
croches qui ne perdent pas d en face aux
nouvelles séries de mesures
va écouter 90 le ja
il y avait 9 509 patients acolytes dans
nos hôpitaux parce que les québécois
comprennent la queue on s'approche de
notre capacité maximale est important
d'être capable de continuer à soigner
tout le monde donc pour ça france est
important qu'on soit transparent
j'essayais de l'aide depuis le début
donc qu'on doit d'éviter aux québécois
est évidemment bien il faut partager
cette responsabilité de ensemble puis
moi j'ai confiance que les québécois
vont tout faire pour éviter
qu'ils aient des conséquences
dramatiques pour certains québécois
c'est ce qui met fin aux questions en
français nous allons poursuivre nous
avons une question en anglais pour cible
ici pendant qu'andrew
alors voilà mesdames et messieurs
grand coup ce sont les mesures les plus
sévères en amérique du nord patrick bell
rogers à montréal a posé et l
association
anime aguerri
il dit on est mieux agir